we're approaching the final weekend
before the midterm elections in
Georgia's tight race for governor is
getting national attention former
President Obama will campaign there
today for Democratic candidate Stacey
Abrams she follows Oprah as in Winfrey
who hosted two rallies for Abrams
yesterday Vice President Mike Pence was
also in Georgia supporting the
Republican candidate for governor brian
kemp Nancy Cordes is covering the
Georgia election in College Park just
outside of Atlanta Nancy good moring was
a busy day in Atlanta yesterday it sure
wasn't it's going to be a busy day today
because this is the last day of early
voting before voters go to the polls
again on election day and polls show
that this race for governor is a virtual
tie which is why Democrats are hoping
that Oprah's unique get-out-the-vote
effort will make a difference Oprah hit
the stage and the sidewalk Thursday
[Laughter]
urging Georgians to get out and vote
tourniquets fair did you have really
yeah I think you should do that she came
to support Stacey Abrams who is vying to
become the nation's first female
african-american governor Oprah
addressing minority voters directly for
anybody here who has an ancestor who
didn't have the right to vote and you
are choosing not to vote wherever you
are in this state in this country you
are dishonouring your family
[Applause]
Oprah's visit got a rise out of 78 year
old Georgia congressman and Civil Rights
icon John Lewis later I'm emotional I
heard Oprah Winfrey's in the state today
I'm kind of a big deal to vice president
hence flew in to bolster the Republican
candidate Georgia Secretary of State
Brian Kemp this ain't Hollywood this is
Georgia the president took came from
Washington the woman that she's
supporting is not qualified to be the
governor of Georgia by any stretch of
the imagination I am the most qualified
candidate for this job I am a business
owner I am a political leader
I asked Abrams how well she knew Oprah
before they campaigned together
yesterday and she says she met her once
back when she was in college she said
that when Oprah called her earlier this
week to offer her help she pulled over
to the side of the road and had in her
words a small aneurysm well for Oprah
you can see the connection obviously
they're both from the same state but but
not just that yeah they're from
Mississippi yeah not just that you see
her really wanting to get people out to
vote yeah I'm not gonna say that they
were close friends because I think Stacy
mentioned you know they met a long long
long time ago but Oprah certainly been
following this campaign been reading a
lot about Stacy and following Stacy's
campaign and really believes in her
that's the only reason why she was out
there but she said guys that she walked
away feeling very energized by the
process going door to door she said
people came running out in their pajamas
she was walking with her little
clipboard and had her words that she
wanted to say so she was very excited to
do it and felt very gratified and
grateful by it so we will see what
happens and her messages always just get
out and vote regardless of who you're
supporting and in her case she's she's
supporting Stacey Abrams but just get
out and vote this process is so
important in this election is so
important and that'd resonance to that
point about disrespecting your ancestors
in Georgia where or in the minority
community feels like the voter support
there is voter suppression and active
voter suppression to keep them from the
polls and even the president's remarks
talking to somebody down in Georgia the
notion of lacking qualifications for
African Americans in jobs that have been
traditionally held by white people they
hear in a questioning of qualifications
just as with the questioning of the
president whether he was an American
citizen a claim they hear those same
kinds of echoes that have a long history
in American life then John they have
shown the voter suppression is real
we've shown it on this newscast for
instance your name is Jo HN if it was
spelled Jo in on the form that could
disqualify you it's something as simple
as that that's why these are very thats
why people are very frightened in
georgia about what's happening I liked
Oprah Singh
John Lewis dance yeah me too I thought
that was a nice moment you know